CARTER MORGAN: Welcome to "Cloud
Security Basics," a new series
where we explain the
ins and outs of securing
your application
on Google Cloud.
Sound fun?
Then stick around,
because in this episode,
you'll learn who's
responsible for securing what
in your Cloud app.
[THEME MUSIC]
[DIALING]
BRAD ACTOR: Hello,
Cloud Detective.
Today I'm not issuing a
challenge-- only a riddle
for you.
What do you have to do
to secure your cloud
environment by yourself?
CARTER MORGAN: OK,
here's what we know.
When it comes to securing
their cloud environment,
enterprise companies
care about a few things--
consistently delivering
the right service
and the right data to
the right identity.
This can't be something that
only happens some of the time.
It needs to happen for
every single request.
Implementing authorization
and authentication
to make sure that only the right
people have access to resources
and data, proactively preventing
threats because bad actors
are constantly evolving,
and effective cloud security
allows you to be proactive
rather than just reactive.
Complying with
regulatory requirements
of their industry-- not
all, but more and more,
businesses are required
to be compliant,
so that's something you
have to be aware of.
And flexibility and
control so internal teams
can be empowered to act on the
parts they're responsible for
and can control.
To make sure those
areas are covered,
we must harden our
cloud security.
Securing your system falls
into three main levels
of responsibility--
things you're responsible
for, things your provider
is responsible for, and things
you're both responsible for.
There's platform,
infrastructure,
and application-level security.
The user is responsible for
securing their applications,
like setting up proper
authentication, authorization,
and identification for
users in their system.
Google Cloud owns securing
the platform, which
includes managing the physical
machines and data centers,
your application, and data use.
Lastly, infrastructure security
is a shared responsibility,
where Google Cloud
provides tools
to help the user manage their
VMs, network, and data access
needs.
Let's explore this in depth.
So what do you have to
do to secure your cloud
environment by yourself?
Hm.
I know that within these
levels of responsibilities,
there are three main
security actions you can
take to harden your system--
platform and infra actions,
preventative actions,
and forensic actions.
Let me explain.
Infrastructure and
platform actions
are steps you take to make
sure the underlying hardware,
or virtual hardware, are secure.
There are two
components of this--
platform security, which
Google completely manages,
and infrastructure security,
which is managed by the user,
but Google Cloud
provides tools to help.
Platform actions
are steps Google
takes to secure the
hardware and software
tools available over the
internet they provide to users.
This can be anything from
physically securing data
centers to replicating
data across regions
to make sure it's
available, even
in the event of a natural
disaster somewhere.
Infrastructure actions,
on the other hand,
are steps the user takes
to secure the Cloud-based,
pay-as-you-go services such
as storage, networking,
and virtualization
that Google provides.
This could be anything from
changing settings in a load
balancer to selecting a
more secure VM instance
type for your application.
The next class of action
is preventative actions.
These are steps you
take to avoid breaches,
like locking down
access controls.
Much of this happens at
the application level
and includes things like Google
Cloud Identity and Access
Management, or IAM, and Google
Identity Aware Proxy, or IAP,
to limit who has access to
what inside of your system.
So Google provides
tooling to the users
to help define access levels.
And then there are
forensic actions.
These are the steps you take
to track down breaches and stop
them quickly, or, ideally,
to identify and stop
malicious behaviors before
a breach ever even occurs.
One of the main practices here
is logging and monitoring.
By logging activity
within your system
and setting up automatic and
manual monitoring of that data,
you can be alerted of suspicious
activity before it's too late.
Here, again, Google
Cloud provides
tooling to help customers
monitor their environments.
That's it.
That's the answer
to Brad's question.
BRAD ACTOR: Hello, Detective.
I see you solved
my little riddle--
what do you have to do
to secure your cloud
environment by yourself?
I said by yourself.
That was tricky.
But here's the thing--
you were never alone in this.
Cloud security is a shared
responsibility model.
Google handles most of the
infrastructure security.
But you are ultimately
responsible for securing
your applications
and services that
run on that infrastructure.
You can never assume an
application or service
is 100% secure.
But by leveraging
tools that focus
on detection and by
planning for recovery,
you're ensuring your
security model has a chance
at keeping your service safe.
Very good, very good.
You've solved my little
riddle this time.
But be ready.
Because next time,
I want to see what
you'll do if the wrong
identities access your data.
CARTER MORGAN: So there you
have it-- the first episode
of "Cloud Security Basics."
Next episode will focus on the
first of three distinct areas
of cloud security risk--
access.
In the meantime, if you
want to take a deeper
dive into the cloud
security model,
then check out the article
linked in the description
below.
And stay tuned for the rest
of the "Cloud Security Basics"
series, because when
it comes to security,
you can't let bad actors win.
[THEME MUSIC]